so um
so what I like to do today is we we have
a lot of ground to cover
um so I did put an agenda out on the
table for those folks that don't have
one
um my my hope is to be as alexandrian as
possible and kind of cut through
um the bulk of this agenda uh pretty
quickly
um representative Gordon is going to be
looking to maybe get us together in
October to kind of look for the final
disposition so if we can it'd be nice if
we could kind of get through everything
today
um so I'll start with a recap of the
last meeting that we had basically we
had a lot of discussion about what what
is is the caseload at the Human Rights
Commission and I think that we had come
to a place where we were saying right
now as we're staffed uh with five
investigators cases in uh is equal to
cases out so we're in a place uh where
the commission is operating in a steady
state but obviously the question remains
that there's a big backlog and and
what's to be done about that
um next we got into a discussion uh
about uh the requirements of SB 296 and
are the existing resources of the
commission
um adequate to satisfy those
requirements and I think after some good
discussion uh we were pretty much in a
place where we said yes indeed the
resources there given uh the the rate of
removal are adequate we talked uh about
the potential for the immediate removal
to Superior to court if represented by
Council the question was initially asked
what if we just did it across the board
the thinking was maybe just if there's
representation by Council
um we talked um about uh our
recommendation memorandum that had come
from the association of justice and
there was a timeline that went through
that
and basically
um
the the folks over at the Human Rights
Commission were saying the probable
cause standard standard sorry that is
being uh discussed here is something uh
that we are already kind of doing so the
the question that arose out of that was
just uh could we kind of get some
completion data uh before and after you
know the break-in date when when did we
modify the standard in its application
at the commission and did we see uh any
shift uh with respect to investigation
time uh before and after because that
would give us a feel really
um if doing that is going to do anything
to kind of impact the timeline we also
talked about options for limiting the
potential to amend claims and then we
kind of finished the day off uh with a
penalty discussion there were some
recommendations that we could possibly
look at penalties in the memorandum so
there was some concern would that be uh
penalties on an individual basis what
would that look like
um so uh basically we said okay we'll do
some digging and we'll park that for the
next meeting which is today
so that's kind of just a recap of where
we were in the last meeting yes
representative Smith
thank you um
Mr chair
uh
I'm in awe of all the work that you've
done
and I think it's incredible but I have a
couple of different reactions then and I
might be wrong so please correct me for
example I think we concluded that cases
in and cases equal cases out
was not applicable since we were told
that you could they took in 20 to 30
cases a month and that they
um have roughly on average four hearings
a year that's number one and related to
that
was uh in terms of the Staffing when we
were told that the load was cut from 50
to 25 for each investigator
and we were curious about what happened
to the remaining 25 we were told well
they just weren't given to the
investigator so I don't think that
indicates that the Staffing is adequate
um and so on particularly on those two
areas
um
I didn't see agreement and then the
third is the one we've kind of skirted
around several times and that is the
difference in
the length of time for any
um
any case as compared with what is
required by Statute and rules and so
um
I think yours your summary is really
optimistic and I would like it to be
absolutely accurate but I'm not a
hundred percent sure that it is well
thank you yeah thank you and and you are
correct the the Active cases at the
commission
um is about 20 to 25 per investigator
and so the surplus of cases that of of
the 50 that basically is what went into
the backlog
so
um but it was my understanding and the
director can correct me if I'm wrong
with my understanding based on the
testimony that
the accumulation
um was was no longer accumulating that
the accumulation went back to when they
had uh the the the two member staff but
now it's about 200 plus cases in 200
plus cases out but the accumulation that
had accumulated over the course of a
decade really there there's no impact
being made on that so basically a case
comes in we're picking it up in the
order that it was docketed but
everything else just has to go for a
long time because there is nothing
that's really being done to address the
accumulation which is why I think I
think we're in a steady state but
nothing is being done to address the
accumulation that's where I think the
significant backlog does remain which is
why I think it would be interesting to
look to see
um since we have modified the probable
cause standard at the commission
um what are we seeing with respect to
the investigation time and what are we
seeing with respect to the accumulation
um which is you know that that's I think
what what do you mean that we've
modified the probable cause we haven't
no no in the testimony last week the
memorandum that was presented
um
was
stating there were recommendations in
the memorandum that said we need to
modify the the the probable cause
standard to be less of a finding of fact
right which was what it had been in the
past so the director testified that
currently they had modified that
okay
do you see could you go here sir because
I'm people are going to want to hear
what you have to say
good afternoon
um okay so our internal case processing
process was modified the probable cause
standard is still the same but how we
internally process our cases has been
changed
so yeah so my understanding was yeah
because that the probable cause standard
is statutory but it was was my
understanding
that
and maybe I misunderstood this from last
week's testimony that you had been
applying a very aggressive almost kind
of super standard and that you had kind
of dialed that back a little bit to be
more in line with the statute I
understand okay all right and so so yeah
so I I yes so the statutory language of
the standard
has not changed but how you are
approaching that statutory standard
was changed to be more in line with the
memo that was presented last week and so
you said we're already actually doing
that and because we're doing that our
we the the one-year timeline which was a
timeline that was presented is a
timeline that we are meeting was what I
took away from the the discussions that
we had last week is that correct or
incorrect I I understand okay
um
so the memo that was given last week was
is separate from what we're doing
correct that was recommendations on
process okay yes and what had been done
at the commission was there are
um
different
not barriers but different standards
that the complainant must meet at every
step
and what was previously happening was a
very high standard in terms of report
writing and investigation was being done
prior to when it should have been
applied
so in looking at that and looking at how
we can move the process along more
efficiently
not faster in terms of negating Rights
or any anything like that but moving
ourselves efficiently and paying
attention to each standard that's
supposed to be met at each step
we are in line with how we are supposed
to be recognizing those standards at
each step
yeah thank you for the clarification yes
representative Smith
um
you said that specific uh requirements
for the complainant
not for the agency
the complainant brings the charge
and they have to meet Prima fascia
which is that initial at first glance
it's supposed to be here I'm being
docked wages and it has nothing to do
with discrimination it doesn't go to the
Human Rights Commission that would be
the basic triage the introductory triage
right you can call it that sure I mean
we're looking at the legal standard so
it has to meet that legal standard right
once it comes in the door and it is
being investigated then there's a back
and forth so the complainant has made
the charge
the respondent responds as to whatever
they whatever the complainant is saying
that they don't agree with it because
they did whatever that action was and it
was a non-discriminatory reason why they
did those things so they have an
opportunity to respond and then the
complainant has an opportunity to say
well no you that wasn't really what
happened it really happened this way
and so there's a back and forth until
someone fails the test and at that point
in the investigation the investigators
looking at all of the facts all of the
evidence that they have they've done
interviews with Witnesses they've taken
written testimony they've looked at
files and all of those things and then
at a certain point a determination of
probable cause or no probable cause is
made and then the case moves forward
from that point depending on which door
that charge is going into and and how
long does it take then to get from when
the case comes in until probable cause
when the case come the better question
actually let me help you with that one
the better question is from the time
that it's docketed to the time that it's
assigned I think so for me part of this
process has been there's been a lot of
confusion as to the length of time the
entire process takes that the issue is
not once it's assigned to probable cause
the issue is once it's docketed to
assignment that is what sits in pending
and that is what Waits and that is what
has been building once it's assigned
then it moves through pretty pretty
reasonably it depends on the case
it depends on what it is but it moves
through relatively quickly and then the
other metric although I know SB 296 is
specifically speaking about hearings
having a hearing or not having a hearing
is not really the relevant question what
part of what we do hearings are part of
our process but the majority of our
cases settle so the settlement is the
person is the individual being made
whole at some point some sort of way
well that's you know I I said probable
cause I didn't say hearing for that
reason oh I'm sorry may I follow up is
that okay thank you um but for someone
who believes that they have been
aggrieved and believed that the
appropriate place for them to go or the
only place they're legally allowed to go
is is to your agency
the critical time is from the moment
that they submit the complaint
until there's probable cause and things
can move on it is not
the period from when they complain until
it's assigned is your issue it's not the
complainance issue I mean and and so
if meanwhile they're in a difficult
situation that time counts do you have a
problem if I could just the last thing
and then I won't monopolize I problem do
you have to find patterns in when you
get you know you say you average 20 25
something like that a month have there
been any UPS or Downs over the course of
a year or two for example have you been
getting
um
uh
complaints related to the issue of
there's a lot to unpack there
I always make it complicated on purpose
you know sorry
um I I guess the question would be so I
would like to respectfully push back on
the timing
the the whole timing would be an issue
and it's specifically an issue for us
for sure that someone is having to wait
so the important time I personally feel
as the executive director that's really
relevant to us moving things along
quickly for people is the time that a
charge will wait from the from the
moment it's docketed to the time that
it's assigned because once it's assigned
it moves along pretty quickly I mean
obviously there's back and forth
sometimes people ask for people ask for
extensions whether it's attorneys
whether it's individuals that are not
represented that are asking for
extensions and we try to be very
cognizant of allowing people to have
extensions
um in taking with the process especially
people who are not represented but
having to sit and wait where nothing is
effectively being done because there's
not enough staff to just continue to
move through that whether it's
requesting additional information
reminding people about mediation and a
variety of things to either settle those
cases or or be able to continue to get
information in that is a problem and
that is a problem for the complainant
because there's nothing that's being
done specifically because there's not
enough staff to do it so I think it is
very important to include that into the
conversation and to make sure it's clear
that it's not just point A to point Z
it's it's a lot of the steps in between
that are equally as important and
in terms of the information the cases
that we get in we have a variety of
cases that come in every month and yes
there are Ebbs and flows in terms of how
many cases are docketed each month but
that doesn't but that's not really
relevant to the number of cases that are
assigned each month uh specifically
because
we have cases that are pending so it is
very easy to make sure that people have
a caseload of 2025 or it could be a
little more if someone leaves then that
individual who might have 25 cases will
get more cases because someone else has
left
difficult
one
one docketed charge so
I I actually think that the time from
when it's assigned until the probable
cause that actually is an important
time and understanding that because a
lot of the reform work that you're
talking about is happening in that area
and so when you when it comes to the
issue of the backlog
you can address the backlog in just a
couple of ways either a you have to put
in resources you know additional
resources so that you can address the
cases to kind of work the backlog down
or if you don't have those resources
available and you don't at this time we
talked about that in a little bit in the
last meeting you you have to look at
that process from the assignment until
when you're done because when that
happens that's going to shorten the
investigation time it's going to free up
people to allow them I think to get to
the backlog with the resources that you
have and so that's why I think
um that that is an actual important uh
bit of data to look at so one of the
things that we did talk about was with
some of the the changes that you made
and I misspoke about the the probable
cause but with respect to your your
process uh and and and you're
documenting and all that stuff so with
respect to that you had made some
changes you said
and since you have made those changes
one of the things that we want to kind
of understand is had that had a
measurable impact
on the the time the actual meat of the
processing from when it's assigned until
when
um you get a finding a probable cause so
I wanted to talk about is we had any
data on that we able to find anything
with that regard um I think I do have an
answer to that so with respect to that
specific question we began our new
procedures in February of this year okay
and we have increased the number of
however
to look at that equation
as we're continuing to move forward with
the new process and you're going and
we're going to close more yeah
there's still more coming in so it's not
a finite number so that's where the the
issue comes in in terms of resources I
you know and and I understand one of the
things that we talked about last week
was okay we're at steady state so we
pretty much have the amount of cases
coming in equals the amount of cases
going out was well kind of what I walked
away with last week
so are you finding So when you say 50
additional cases because what was the
backlog it was something like 300 cases
uh it's not quite that much but close I
mean it might be like 250. okay so 250
cases so the 50 cases that you so you're
able to process an additional 50 cases
is that since February
over the course of this
yeah yeah
go ahead thank you because for me this
is a very key question
you
saying what I'm hearing is that the
processes you implemented in February
have increased your closure rate
which implies to me
that you're actually starting to reduce
your backlog is that accurate
I mean it's a yes and no so yes with the
number but if cases continue to come in
then you're not necessarily reaching all
of those do you understand I mean you'll
get some for sure but if if you only
have if you have 200 cases and there's
nothing else coming in and then every I
don't know six months you close an
additional 25 cases definitely it's done
right if each person is closing another
well if each person we have five staff
members each person closes 10 above what
they were assigned then that's going to
be 50 cases so you're hitting the
backlog because nothing else is coming
in and it goes away
but when you have more hands that are
lifting the same or more then it
eradicates it so
I guess I don't understand what's not
understood yeah so yeah I would
appreciate a yes or a no
that's all
with the new procedures with the
increased closure rate
is the absolute number of backlogged
cases
going down
somewhat
that would be a yes
Ryan did you have a question
representative Gordon
no
not not at this moment I do have some
comments with regard to if we're just
following up on what representative
Smith has said then no but when we get
back to your agenda I do okay
so no but I just uh
thank you director Malachi for but again
it's an important question because one
of the big concerns everybody has maybe
not as it relates to 296 but just in is
we do have the accumulation rate and we
talked a little bit about resources and
so
understanding the impact of the
procedural changes you made with respect
to that backlog is is critical so it
does sound like it's new it's only been
since February we're only in the
September time frame so we understand
the year over year
things can change uh the amount of
people filing can go up one year or down
the year after but in general
um you're processing more cases and
yes
we had talked about the probable cause
standard
um and so I did
uh have sent out
an email with respect to uh the language
does anybody have any thoughts on that
um it should be and on page two of the
agenda
so according to the statute
determination of probable cause means a
determination made after investigation
that there is sufficient evidence upon
which a fact finder would form a
reasonable belief that the respondent
committed one or more unlawful practices
so um yeah uh just a one minor
correction you had a letter
wrong in one of those words
because you said a reasonable person
would
when the standard is could
like Europe
so yeah I have a thought yes it's the
same thought I had last week the
standard is so low it seems like it
would be
pretty much be very easy to meet that
standard
yeah yeah I have a couple of thoughts
and
just to start out I
one of the and I know this is our last
meeting it should be our last meeting
but
I was wondering if we should have heard
from the chair of the Commissioners or
from the Commissioners themselves
as to
their responsibilities and their duties
because don't they have some involvement
in deciding how the commission should
operate
and
the after we left the last meeting and
as I was driving home was thinking
shouldn't
the chair of the commission
be here
explaining how the commission works and
why it works the way it does but that's
another issue
the probable cause standard I think is
the issue I don't really I I understand
and
and director Malachi does a great job
and she's explained uh and she's very
defensive of the process but I think the
process
is the issue so she's defending the
process and basically saying the process
works if only we had resources
well I don't think the process works
that's my opinion and the process does
it it doesn't work properly because we
are
addressing the issue of probable cause
we're basically having an investigator
decide the case before the commission
ever hears it in fact
decides the case because the commission
isn't hearing any cases it's only
hearing four cases a year
so
uh and I I was uh we we have another
email which we received uh at least the
committee members received indicates the
Department of Labor
when they have complaints come in
they uh they don't have an investigation
of probable cause they look at it make a
determination based upon the filings as
to whether or not there's a sufficient
basis to move forward and then schedule
a hearing
and it seems to me that there needs to
be some alteration with regard to the
probable cause process because
and
and yes I understand there's a delay in
appointing investigators perhaps because
we don't have enough investigators
but I also heard testimony earlier that
when the investigator has it these cases
are lasting the investigator may not get
appointed for a year
but these cases aren't getting closed
so something's happening in that process
and that's and that's that determination
of probable cause
I said on another committee the Ethics
Committee where basically we do our
triage a complaint comes in and we look
and see if on the face it makes a
reasonable claim but once it makes a
reasonable claim
we don't hire an investigator to look
what we do is we have both parties come
in basically before the Ethics Committee
explain and then we make a determination
of probable cause and whether or not
there's a sufficient basis to go forward
with charges
and it seems to me that there ought to
be some alteration in this probable
cause process that's more reasonable and
appropriate than having an investigator
it seems to me that right now the
process as I understand it is the
investigator can't decide probable cause
but basically
does a full investigation makes a
recommendation and for the most part my
guess is the commissioner Robert a a
commissioner rubber stampson says yep
you're right and so
uh it seems to me that the Commissioners
should be making could be making that
determination and then making that
instead of defending the process the one
thing I haven't heard
and that's why I sort of would like to
hear the commissioner here I have a
commissioner here the one thing I
haven't heard is
we think our system is acceptable that
that we we think our system is properly
serving the people of the State of New
Hampshire I'd like somebody from the
commission to tell me they think it as
adequately serving the people in the
and if they could do that then I would
be surprised
there needs to be some change some
modification to make this system work
and and serve serve our constituents
those are my thoughts so uh to follow up
on that a little bit oh actually
representative De Lorenzo you had a
question oh yes it's a question for
representative Gordon
um representative Gordon you mentioned
that
um practically the investigator is the
one who's deciding whether the case has
Merit and goes forward when you feel it
should be the Commissioners is that
correct
right now it is the Commissioners only
they're taking the recommendation of the
investigator so but my guess is that
they're rubber stamping for the most
part yeah
okay well thank you that recommendation
thank you for your response um and I
think that that's a big problem because
I think that we want to see
transparency between all of the moving
parts of the um Human Rights Commission
for instance um
an investigator does his investigation
cut and dried hands it over to the
commission and like let them make the
decision instead of the investigator
making you know driving the driving a
bus
and I think it would be
more fair and more clear
thank you representative De Lorenzo so
uh representative Gordon just uh so it's
my understanding then that if you look
at the legal language
uh in the profitable cause you're saying
actually
that's adequate
it's more just on the process side
and probably because is is a
uh it's a it's it should be a very low
standard
okay the problem will cause the names of
Supreme Court said probable cause is
less than more likely than not
and More Than A Reasonable Suspicion
that has case law that says that and so
it's a very low standard and that's the
standard to move forward
to adjudication
but what's happening is you have an
investigator from what I can see who's
basically going out there doing this
full investigation
and coming back and saying hey you know
this this this k
this is this is going to be the outcome
of the case basically
um and
and then based upon that the parties
settle
but it it seems to me that it should be
probable cause should be the the
beginning of the
should be the beginning of a process as
opposed to as it is right now the end of
the process
because what is happening is they're
going through this whole process of
probable cause and then as the Director
just said most people are settling and
the reason they're settling is because
you basically decided the case
so I just I just want to kind of follow
up you know with a question back for you
and then maybe a follow-up question for
the for the director so with obviously
you've been a judge and you've sat on
the Ethics Committee we have
um the the the research
um from uh Kristen Grant
um so
in those
labor board Ethics Committee when it
comes to probable cause is there an
investigative process in those relative
bodies and what's its nature relative I
mean we kind of we kind of talked about
the the investigation that goes on in
the Human Rights Commission
comparatively speaking where do you see
it
um in these other bodies in in most
cases it's it's not uh in most bodies
it's not an investigator that's going
out and investigating it's the parties
that are responsible for showing the
evidence that's needed to meet probable
cause and
so for example uh if you have a criminal
case a felony case uh you have to have
probable cause in order for somebody to
go to a trial that probably will cause
in a felony case is supposed to be made
within 20 days it was at least as far as
felonies first it's concerned or
felonies in this in the circuit court
within 20 days and it's up to the police
to say you know this is the evidence
that we have it's up for the defendant
to say that's not true
and you make that determination and once
you make the determination a quick
determination then you schedule it for
trial and then the parties can do
whatever
the parties do whatever research they
thank you representative Gordon director
Malachi the Human Rights Commission is
kind of
it's a bit of a unique entity
and it does have
so maybe you could kind of walk us
through some of the history
um why would the Human Rights Commission
have such a departure from these other
bodies with respect to uh the nature of
the investigation
thank you so that would actually be a
question for the legislature who created
us in 1965.
um but part of the confusion I think
that's being there's a lot of
messing around with a lot of different
things we are not criminal and so a lot
of the explanations that have been given
specifically deal with criminal cases
which are very different from
administrative law cases and I think
that's part of the problem with the
confusion as to what we're discussing
what's also being missed is that the
commission is we are police officers we
are a district attorney we are a defense
attorney to some degree if there's a
hearing and we have to represent the
complainant
we do a variety of things we're the
judge we have a jury we are all of those
elements all put together in one and so
the problem is when we're discussing
probable cause in a criminal case as the
judge gets it and the people come before
them before the judge him or her
what is eloquently been missed is the
Nuance all of the investigation all of
the information gathering all of the
determination of can we go forward can
we have a search warrant Can We Gather
this information that's done before it
gets to the judge we do all of that so
that is a part of our process it's not
that everything walks into the door nice
and neat when you come into a courtroom
all of the legwork all of the research
all of the investigation of the in
talking to Witnesses and looking under
bushes and finding pieces of paper and
books and all of those things all that's
been done
so when the judge gets it in a criminal
case that work has been done when we
when something walks into our door it's
as if someone walked into the police
department and said someone stole my car
now someone has to be assigned to take
the intake of who what who you are what
happened to your car and gather that
information and then it goes through the
process we do all of those processes we
are not simply a court where something
is complete and walks into us and then
we make a determination and then
whatever happens after that happens we
are all of those processes from souped
thank you director
um so and and I take your point with
respect to the difference uh between the
Human Rights Commission and say a
criminal court
um one I I did ask
um uh Kristen to give us the the
difference uh between uh the Human
Rights Commission and the labor
department which I I thought were kind
of similar which is why I kind of asked
her to kind of look at that and in that
case
um from if you just go to the second
page of the agenda a hearing in the
Department of Labor on the other hand
does not require showing a probable
cause so it looks like in that situation
it just goes forward
um so again I'm just trying to
understand there's there's very very
different approaches here and why
um if you have any understanding of why
um there is a departure between say the
the process that um the labor folks we
use and and the process that you would
use
I'm not I'm not familiar with how the
labor department is set up I mean I know
they have significantly more
investigators than we do so that makes a
huge difference I'm not familiar with
their process so I can't really I can't
speak to that
um I don't know why they don't do an
investigation first or or they do it
later I don't know you had your hand up
sure you could sit over there we did
it's a work it's a work session so you
could
oh
I got a lot of points I want to address
but I'm going to try and keep it simple
so we can move through it
yes thank you representative Smith why
does the HRC have such departure from
the investigation that other agencies do
I think that's because of the law that
the HRC has been designed to
administer
um
there's that whole McDonald Douglas
burden shifting framework for employment
law which basically says employee you
have to present some evidence of your
Prima fashion case employer did you have
a legitimate non-discriminatory business
reason for doing the action and then the
employee gets to say well actually their
reason is is a bunch of
yes a bunch of Hui it's not right and
here's what actually happened
um so I think the HRC does have to have
a little bit of a different
investigation than other agencies but I
agree the process can be changed it can
be streamlined and made better
um
I think that was the point I wanted to
I can hold off on my other points for
now please yes
well no just just just a quick follow-up
so
um so they have that standard over at
the labor department
do you have any knowledge as to because
I wasn't around when the law was written
in 1965. so as to why they would have
the the different standard at the Human
Rights Commission my knowledge and I'm
going to invite my my colleague Megan
Douglas to jump up and correct me if she
has a different view but my knowledge of
that is when this law was implemented we
wanted a gatekeeper to keep these cases
from flooding the court system and so we
wanted the HRC to basically operate
at the gate and cut off any frivolous
claims you know for example if somebody
says
um
my employer said that I have to tuck in
my shirt to come to work so he's
discriminating against me because I'm a
woman something like that would be a
clearly frivolous claim
and and that's the type of stuff that
the HRC is supposed to weed out before
it ever makes it to the court so that we
don't clog up the court system and I
think that's how that got started in the
okay
unless there's yeah unless there's
someone here from labor that could speak
specifically to how labor does their
process I don't think we have an answer
I mean I know what we do generally
reflects how the EEOC which is the
federal
um uh agency does their cases we
generally generally reflect their
process so I can only assume dangerous
words but when the HRC was created that
it would reflect what was statutory for
the federal government
that would be my guess if I had to
all right so I think we we I think we're
in a place right now where we talked
about the probable cost standard we're
comfortable with the language we're
saying
are there some things maybe that we want
to do around process
um so we'll go on to that
representative Smith
thank you very much
um when you were able to go and meet
with the staff which I think you did at
the beginning of September if I recall
or did you have an opportunity to read
um one of the HRC reports to see what it
was like
no I did not
one I'm just curious about this whole
question of the detail
that um that are competent
responsible investigator
appeals is necessary to go into that
report which seems to take a lot of time
and I was just curious
thanks Marissa and I just want to say
Representatives
um Megan and I didn't get a chance to
connect before this meeting so we're
happy to have copies made and sent
electronically to you all so that this
isn't the only copy
um
yeah
um so
I thought it would be helpful uh for you
all to have a visual of of what um the
investigation looks like as finally
documented in the probable cause or no
probable cause determination report
um the problem in disseminating it is
that it's it's confidential in this case
the
um the plaintiff wanted to stay at the
commission precisely because it was a
confidential process she didn't want to
go to court
um and so I took some time to redact the
information
and it took it took quite a while
because the report is lengthy
um but what in my view the report shows
I'll just I'll tell you it's
one
two three
four
five
six
seven
I could have counted the page numbers
huh nine single spaced Pages uh it looks
sort of like a summary judgment decision
um it looks it looks uh like the
investigator here did this over the
course of years
um
and
in this case despite the fact that the
plaintiff had
two three Witnesses corroborating
um
corroborating her her theory of the case
no probable cause was found
and so I thought it would be a good it
would be helpful to you also this one
this investigation shows
that the investigator was not able to
contact
an important witness until he was he
separated from employment for 19 months
so it was it was
um a year and a half that he was out of
the job where this lady worked
um and consequently he didn't remember
her at all at least he said he didn't
and he wasn't able to say anything that
was helpful to her even though years
prior she would had identified him as an
important Witness
so
um again no probable cause was found
um
I I I'm happy to I'm
I'm happy to to to send this around the
table I I think I did a fairly good job
of of redacting
um I don't know if that means that
necessarily it's publicly accessible
what
what does everybody think about that
huh
yeah
um
okay
well I guess you can look at it from
afar
um it does exist I mean I guess I'll
you'll have to accept my representations
as to what what's in here I can tell you
a little bit about the case if that
um
the iris is stemmed here I received it
January 22nd my birthday uh in 2020.
um complainant was fired
yeah I just want to respond to
representative Smith's question a little
bit about what do these reports look
like
um one thing Megan said was that even
though the the plaintiff in this case
had corroborating Witnesses no probable
cause was found that's really important
because the way the plaintiff
identifying corroborating Witnesses
probably occurred at that third stage
after the employer has already given
their reason and the plaintiff says no
that's a bunch of Hui here are my
Witnesses here's why these are important
if the probable cause standard as
written had been correctly applied
the plaintiff should have had probable
cause because like representative Gordon
said what's happening is that they're
deciding the merits of the case and
that's not what's supposed to be done
they're just supposed to be saying have
you given me something to believe that
the type of discrimination you say
happened actually did
and if you've given me something even if
I don't necessarily believe it if some
reasonable person could that's good
enough check the box move on
and this is so detailed representative
Smith and analyzing every potential fact
in the case that it's going above and
beyond what's required
say I have gender discrimination at work
and I've got five examples of how that's
happening to me if the probable cost
standard is applied correctly I only
have to give the HRC one before they can
say okay you get to move to the next
step
because I just have to give them some
credible evidence that a reasonable
representative Gordon in effect that's
an adjudication of the claim
and and what happens what happened to
this plaintiff is that she didn't
because no probable cause was found she
has
she has no relief at all under RSA 354a
she can't go to Superior Court and she
can't bring a 354a plane it's done she
could appeal the no probable cause
decision
um which I've done once and that case
has been
it was remanded to the commission and
it's now going on six years for the
judication
representative De Lorenzo for Megan Hi
Megan um so
in that particular case you were
speaking of whether they found no
probable cause and you know the case was
like just dropped right
well is there an option or an Avenue to
go before the EEOC on a Case no because
the charge is dually filed with
um
the Human Rights Commission and the EEOC
there they have a work sharing agreement
so that one will investigate claims
under both Title VII and RSA 354a now
this this employee
um
could have
um brought claims in court under Title
VII this is a gender discrimination case
she was a a female boss who cursed in in
the workplace and it was decided that
she broke
the ethical code of the of the company
meanwhile there was a comparator
employee a male who was behaving pretty
badly on the regular and nothing
happened to him and that was the basis
of her her claim she could have a
brought title seven claims in court but
she wanted to Avail of the confidential
process the industry in which she worked
was very
uh
I don't know what the word is in insular
I mean there's very close
um sorry
yes yes and actually she after she was
let go from this job she got a new job
in another
you know uh employer in the same Biz and
um mysteriously that job
just evaporated it was offered her and
then right when she was about to start
it was taken away and there were there
were facts suggesting that there was a a
meeting held between the former employer
and the new employer
so there you go that's why she wanted to
stay at the at the commission
yeah
I guess though I'm
I don't know how to proceed at this
point with obviously we said that we
think that the standard itself the
statutory language of of the standard is
good
so this now just comes down to the the
application in this particular case you
know we're going forward with a full
adjudication it sounds like
um
so
do we do we look at
bringing in statutory language that
really tightens up that process or I
think that's
that's a big nut to pull off
representative McLean yes I could I
actually have an idea about that and I
don't think we need to bring in
statutory language I think we could do
it with the rules of the agency which
have been expired now for five ish years
the rules are several years well yeah
the three sections of the rules are
expired but we could amend those rules
um
to address these issues that we're
discussing and I've actually our memo
that we set forth with the one year
timeline
I think would address most of these
issues and this morning I've thought of
new ideas to streamline that even more
and make it even better cut down the
investigation time but that would allow
in my view the HRC to allocate their
resources such that they could
simultaneously investigate new cases
coming in and address the backlog in
more meaningful numbers because we'd be
we'd be decreasing their duties per
investigator they'd have less things on
their plate than the way they've been
doing things
and for example this memo that you all
should have
at
we put first quarter investigator has
initial this is at the bottom number
three investigator has initial
discussion with complainant to determine
what documents and other evidence are
necessary to the case instead of doing
that we could cut that step and we could
put the form five the form that
complainants fill out their charge of
discrimination on we could add a second
page to the form five that has a
checklist of documents that the
complainant has to identify at the
outset for the commission I believe
these documents exist that are relevant
and will show you that I I've met my
proper cost standard please go get them
investigator and all the complainant has
to do is check the box of the types of
documents that might exist
and then at the investigation phase we
can and this would take some time but a
group of employment lawyers Nila and
nhaj could work together to devise
checklists by the type of claim such
that when the investigator gets into the
investigation all they have to do is is
look at this checkbox list and say
have they offered me some evidence that
they're disabled check the box yes have
they offered me some evidence that they
asked for accommodation yes have they
offered me some evidence that they were
terminated because they offered because
they asked for accommodation yes if so
proceed to commissioners
so
pardon my ignorance since that's so
since that's
um
being taken up potentially in in the
rules which is saying have been expired
for for quite some time
um
and this is just me being ignorant
what what would the mechanism for that
be and and would we as a legislature
have a have a role in that or what what
is what is the mechanism by which that
comes to pass
I believe the rules are amended through
gel car and my understanding which may
not be correct my understanding is that
the HRC itself is responsible for
amending those rules and submitting them
to gel car under the APA and I see
nodding heads so I'm thinking I'm maybe
right on this one but
I would be willing and I can't speak for
other employment lawyers except for this
one but you know we'd be willing to help
come up with some rules so that the
agency doesn't have to do this on their
own we know they have other work to do
and set setting time and people aside to
come up with new rules is difficult
I'm sure we can gather up some other
employment lawyers as well and I'd also
be happy to have committee input on you
know our drought the employment lawyers
drafts of the rules see what what you
guys think about those and then maybe we
work with the HRC directly to get those
passed through gel car just an idea I'm
yes representable yeah and uh what we
would do is recommend to be a commission
to rewrite the rules
a special Commission
okay well so we're an interim study we
we have a bill and we say we're going to
study that and we'll figure out what to
recommend
well what we can recommend might be to
have a commission to rewrite the rules
under which the HRC is operating not
necessarily I mean accepting the statute
where it is
but just looking at rewriting how the
commission is actually operating
so that's a that's one thing we can do
from here
I think that would be great and I also
know that from my memo
I had written in here that we need some
type of mechanism for enforcement or
penalty and I know I didn't provide any
suggestions about how we might do that
we've come up with some ideas
um RSA 189 13 and 189 31 are statutes
governing the dismissal of teachers and
essentially what it says is if a teacher
does certain bad things they can be
dismissed and the superintendent gets to
refer that teacher for dismissal to the
school board who then holds a little
hearing it's more like a meeting but
they call it a hearing and the school
board makes a determination and the
teacher might have to hit the road we
could do something very similar here
where
executive director acts as
superintendent and the Commissioners act
as a school board so if we outline these
new rules and we come up with a one year
or less process by which HRC can get a
case done from start to finish and we
see investigators or not we if the
executive director sees investigators
who are not doing doing that who are not
satisfactorily completing their job
duties the executive director shall
refer that in that investigator to the
Commissioners for review the
Commissioners will sit with the
investigator is there good cause for the
reason you're not performing your duties
is it a delay of someone else tell me
what happened and the Commissioners get
to decide whether or not the
investigator continues at the commission
I think that's something we could write
right into the rules as well
I think it might work because it's it's
borrowing from a republic employee
process right
um and it would give the executive
director sufficient control
yes representative Smith
thank you um you've all been terrific
you've given us lots of help and I think
all of us in this room want to see this
this agency work
I personally am not thrilled with what
you just suggested because the problem
is
that the investigators are doing now
what they are expected to do and what
the and what the director holds them
to do in terms of how long the cases go
and whatever
so I don't think
that that solves anything I think we
have to solve the underlying issue which
is the
the fact that the investigators working
hard and doing due diligence have in
fact ended up acting as almost in the
the director of being judge and jury
and um
it seems to me that
we don't have to form a commission which
can go on forever and ever we don't have
to do any of those things what we have
to do is say very clearly that the
language
um the language should clarify the fact
that in order to get to probable cause
it it is just to establish certain basic
facts and that is probable cause
probable cause is not the trial
um and and that can be done and we can
uh
uh gel cars meanwhile should be asking
why five years have passed and and there
hasn't been a review of the rules
um and all of that we can do in in
recommendations
and that would put when the new jail car
is formed after the election
um
we can be right there and
related to the other efforts that we're
we're working on and and move this along
I I think that everybody in the
commission it is is acting in good faith
they're doing what they think they're
expected to do and
we just disagree with what they're
expected to do they're not expected
the investigator is not expected
to conduct what I'm calling a trial just
in shorthand I think we all know what I
mean
um and
that should make
Ms Malachi's work a heck of a lot easier
um it seems to me and we would be
helping her address what seems to be one
of her very real concerns which is the
backlog
and if I may just respond briefly yes
please um I agree with you
representative Smith that I think the
people there are working in good faith
and I don't want to pet agencies are
made of people and people are subject to
human error even when they're doing
their best job and and putting their
best foot forward so if we were going to
do some type of change to the process
and the rules I would propose that we
first revise the process like we've been
talking about a one-year timeline
checklist Etc and then we delay
implement we give that we give the
investigators time to adjust to this new
these new workplace expectations
and then at some point maybe we consider
implementing the process of if executive
director sees people failing to
satisfactorily complete their job duties
she may consider referring them to the
Commissioners
um
try to
do the right thing
ideally
as painful as this process has been for
all of us and it has been very big
blowing up for me and I think for
everybody else ideally we can come out
of this
um
with a dead or able to meet the needs of
the citizens of the state who were alive
on the Human Rights Commission and
and make it possible for the staff to do
her job and their job isn't
to an effective to trials
yeah I'm so I I think yeah I think you
know I've never worked in in state
governments but I'm certain that like
any other agency even in the private
sector that you know director Malachi
holds reviews with her people and if
they're not performing then you know
there's accountability there but what I
was thinking about and I was giving a
lot of thought especially in light of we
got a memo from the committee researcher
just looking at other agencies
um and it doesn't seem to be a lot of
you know penalizing individuals I was
thinking something I just want to get
your thoughts along the lines of you
know in the rules process
really codifying if there's
non-cooperation with the commission like
when I was in there and I was speaking
with folks they say you know in the past
um we would ask for this and there might
be people dragging their their feet or
things of this nature and sometimes when
we were really overwhelmed we would let
that go because we were overwhelmed and
actually it gave us a little bit of a
breather but I I was thinking maybe if
you're going to revisit the rules from a
penalty perspective it might just be if
you're non-complying or non-cooperating
that's ground you know for immediate
loss of your case or something like that
I was thinking something along those
lines what are your what are your
thoughts on that
I think that I think that certainly if
if a respondent isn't
um compliant with an investigator's
request for information for example then
no probable cause should be found I mean
sorry probable cause should be found
right my mistake
um I think what Sam and I were trying to
brainstorm
was well what what happens if we've we
have a rule in the statute that says
investigation shall be done in two years
and they're just not
um and they're they're not and and
they're not for for reasons that aren't
um sound
right
um we wanted you we thought you all had
questions about about accountability and
enforcing whenever we put in 354a and so
we we tried to come up with something
that
um
held people accountable but also you
know gave people process and rested most
of the authority in in the executive
director for accountability with that's
what that's why we we looked to the
teacher statute okay
I can't think of any I can't think of
any situation where an agency is a body
is punished for not doing its job I I I
couldn't think of
any
analogous situation so that's why we
looked to the teacher statute too and I
would just add on to that if we clarify
the standard alone I don't think that's
going to be enough to move these cases
through quickly enough to get a
significant reduction in the backlog I
think they have a very hard job over
there and I think we can make it work
with the resources they've got if we
just
give them some tools you know it's a com
it's a complex area of the law but
luckily we have a bunch of employment
lawyers practicing this area regularly
who can give them tools to simplify
their job
um
I wish that I had a checklist of
elements of the law at my fingertips
every single day that'd be awesome
because they'd make my job simpler we
could do that for them
you know I I do agree
um that further clarifying the probable
cause language you know based on some of
the discussion today and the comments
you know from a representative Gordon
we're probably in a good place with
respect to that language it it it's I
think it's just a just a question of of
application
um but I would
oh did you have a question
okay so but but I I did I did want to
give the the director we've been talking
a lot about the fact that we haven't had
rules in a while and we'd like to go
back and revisit the rules and things
like that so I would like just to give
you the opportunity to give your
thoughts on that uh do you think that's
a good way to go
um
why is it uh
just yeah just what what are your
thoughts with respect to basically
moving through the rules process in this
area
foreign
thank you so much to unpack
um we do need to go through gel car
period full stop
um I don't agree with the majority of
what complainants bar shared you know we
could as soon as something comes in and
it meets prima facie we could just
Market probable cause and move on
whether the respondent responds or not I
mean that would certainly be easier and
we would move things through I don't
think that's what any of us want because
then that's not giving the respondent an
opportunity to respond so part of the
process is that there's checks and
balances along the way and based on the
suggestions it's removing some of those
checks and balances I think the Attorney
General's office is smart enough to
assist us with any check sheets that we
might need I don't think we need their
assistance in doing that I appreciate
the offer we do have internal things but
I think part of it goes back to there's
still a lack of clear understanding as
to what we do these sessions whether
it's a hearing or these meetings are
very specific questions and very pointed
questions which is great but unless you
come and look and look at a charge as
it's walking in and take some time with
us to understand our process you're
still missing so much of the nuance and
the report that was shared with you was
from 2020 which was part of the problem
we don't do reports like that anymore
but if you have a complainants bar that
is slowing down the process if we're
going to assess penalties then everybody
gets a penalty not just one side so I
there are some areas of the rules that
we would like to tighten there are some
things that need explanations there's
some things that we do that maybe we
shouldn't do anymore prohawk viche long
conversation but putting that on the
record maybe we don't need to do those
and then that removes some opportunities
for certain attorneys outside of the
state to practice before us maybe
there's a different process that doesn't
involve us that that should take place
so that's something important but I
think the agency itself with the
guidance of the Attorney General's
office can manage to make it through
jail car looking at our rules having our
commissioners approve them and then that
whole process is public anyway so if
others want to make comments and
suggestions they're welcome to do so it
doesn't mean that we need to adopt them
representative De Lorenzo
thank you Mr clear
um thank you Miss Malachi thank you for
all of your hard work
um so I was wondering is there a
National Organization of professionals
like Professional Organization for state
anti-discrimination agencies that you
that you might be a member of or
different states and members of
um other than the EEOC because that's
who we practice with we usually are in a
work sharing agreement so other than
that that's all that I'm aware of
I thought it might be helpful if there
were a National Association of you know
folks who work for anti-discrimination
state agencies because that's you know
that's where a lot of um you know um
practices get polished and
agencies
um
they
I guess I would say they advocate for
themselves and learn new practices and
there's always training and stuff yes um
well the eeoc's process is a bit
different
um and they do move it a lot faster
because what they do is they set
priorities every year so let's say
um
immigrant workers minority workers and
women are their 2023 priorities if your
case isn't really rock solid you are
dismissed there is no investigation
they give you a right to sue and you're
out the door you're done so that would
help us as well if we adopted what the
EEOC did but but the commission based on
how it's created has elected not to do
that and to provide full investigation
that's relative to whoever's asking the
question but but to provide an
investigation so everything that walks
in the door
is going to get something someone look
is really looking at it not just well
this doesn't quite meet our criteria or
this one isn't very strong there could
be something there but it makes Prima
fascia but that's it and then it gets
follow up so does your do your work is
at your agency attend any HUD trainings
on Fair Housing that type of thing so
there is a HUD training annually and the
EEOC participates in that it's a civil
rights training and they do attend that
every year I have made sure there's
money in my budget for them to attend
that and if there are any trainings that
are online at this point because of
covid things are a lot more accessible
whether the EEOC is offering it we
always take those trainings or one of
the other sister agencies in New England
that offer something the staff will take
those or if there are other trainings
that are approved they will take those
as well
representative Smith
good question
um
you've heard to the complainant bar and
um the earlier Witnesses conferred to
refer to the employment
bar so
in in that case I don't know I should
ask you or or that
whether all the attorneys
in the employment bar are there to
represent the complainants rather than
employers there are attorneys that
represent both sides
so like the attorneys we have here they
customarily will have they represent an
individual that's bringing a charge and
then there are other attorneys that will
represent the company that is responding
to the charge but so the group that
well let me ask you so do you
when you gave us suggestions are the
suggestions only from those people who
yeah director Ed
um
started off at the last session or the
session before that just saying that it
would seem to me that if I were a
litigant that I would have a reasonable
expectation that my case would be
resolved in a fairly timely manner maybe
in a year
that might not be consistent with the
current statute
but it seems to me that if I were to go
to court I would expect my case or I
hope my case would be resolved within a
year
and
and that's not happening now and we're
not doing it within two years where it's
taking longer than that so
and from what you just said we were
talking about making changes in the
rules in order to
facilitate change to maybe speed up the
process to make it work and perhaps get
it down to a year
so
but you've indicated that you don't
think that there's a knee I I don't want
to quote you but basically what you've
said is you don't see a need for major
changes in the rules or some changes
that need to be made but no major
changes in the way you go about doing
things in the rules
so
other than adding resources which is
what you've said in the past is you just
need more
investigators more people
other than adding resources
how would you go about bringing that
time frame down to a year
thank you and actually time in court is
two and a half years so longer
um
part of bringing that changing that time
frame is doing the internal changes that
we've already done
okay and then continuing to look at
other areas that could make things move
faster so is it we're working right now
on creating a list actually a checklist
but a list that goes to the respondent
in their notice letter to say so we
already tell them to hold on to all the
information but reminding them that you
can send in on both sides if there's
information that's important to your
charge send it in you don't need to wait
until something is assigned part of it
is is Staff turnover I mean I'm losing
someone now to the federal government so
some people they get in you're training
them and then they don't work out so
they're terminated some people get in
they're doing a great job and they move
on to make more money whether it's
within the state or outside of the state
and when that happens because we have
five investigators when you lose one
person the that's a fifth of your
Workforce which means the people who are
already doing what they're doing are
taking on those cases that were assigned
because someone's already made them you
know reached out so they're taking those
cases on which means what's what's
waiting Waits a little longer until
those cases continue forward so that's
the other part as to why it's important
to have additional staff because if
someone leaves or if someone's
terminated you know they leave on hey I
found a better job that's great or they
are not doing a good job and they're
terminated you don't have such a seismic
shift in your Workforce and something
that hasn't been really discussed I have
I don't have an administrator in my
office right now and I haven't since
2020. one of my investigators whose job
it is to investigate is doing
administrative
um
administrative case work as well as her
investigations
so
that's that's all a part of it it is
very nuanced and that is why not fully
understanding what we do the limitations
that we're facing and how we're doing it
um is a challenge and because the staff
was cut then that was in 2011 that was
why the time frame I believe was
increased to two years if you want to
make it one year in the statute that's
fine but I need more staff in order to
do it because if I only have the five or
if I end up with four and one person
leaves there is no way to make that work
when you don't have the individuals that
are responsible for their key things so
along with administrative one
investigator doing administrative work I
do it as well
and everything else that is on my plate
to do so to answer your question more
fully we will continue to look at what
policies and procedures internally we
can change and that is why there is such
an amazing relationship with the AG's
office to help us look at this to tweak
and then I'm constantly talking to the
investigators and we've come up with
tool kits and things to send out to
unrepresented folks so they can do a lot
of some of the charges on their own it
still has to be looked at but then they
can do some of that writing on their own
which relieves some of one piece of for
intake but it doesn't change the volume
of things that are coming in and the
phone calls and the constant
any other thoughts or comments
yes representative Smith
thank you um when you submitted your
request to the governor
did you uh request additional staff I
did
good for you thank you
I requested four investigators and
um a training person so that we can
actually make some make some Headway in
what's happening in the state and I have
a paralegal and I've requested to make
that person full-time and to also have
my admin readminister the refunded or
funded again I'm not sure the quite the
correct term for that as well as
having the part-time person in intake
having the funds put back for that then
we would be fully staffed and I feel
like we could really make a big dent in
so I think we're at a place right now we
kind of went through the meat of the oh
yes
one thing I just want to clarify and
that's that's probably an error on my
part because I get a little excited I
talk quickly I skip over things
um I am not advocating that we deprived
the respondents a chance to respond
because that would actually be contrary
to what the law requires I am just
advocating that we simplify the process
of employee makes initial claims
employer responds employee then responds
to employers response
um second point I would make is that I
know director Malachi feels that the HRC
with the a assistant with the attorney
general's assistance and working with
gel car is sufficient to get these rules
passed respectfully I would say that
that's been the situation for five-ish
however many years the rules have been
expired and clearly that's not working
so I think some additional and I agree
with director Malachi I think they
probably do need additional resources my
proposal is offering them free resources
nobody has to pay for my time to help
them come up with rules and I would not
profess to know the ins and outs of what
they do on a daily basis so I would want
to work with director Malachi and anyone
else from the Human Rights Commission
who's willing to help us get rules
passed so I'm not there every day I
don't know what goes on inside those
walls but I do
know the law that I practice in and
I and some others and we can gather a
bigger group if we ever get to that
point are happy to pitch in our time and
resources free of charge to get things
moving I respect that director Malachi
has taken the initiative to implement
internal processes to improve things I
think that's really hard to do when you
are under resourced and you're
struggling just to keep up with the
day-to-day but
if internal measures were enough I don't
think we'd be here right now and that's
not to be dismissive to director Malachi
I think she's doing a great job it's
just that I think she's got a lot on her
plate and maybe some help would be nice
that's all I have a question
representative dilorenzo all right
um well thank you for your presentation
and as you were speaking I was wondering
if there are resources that may be able
to help the um Human Rights Commission
workers
and that could be maybe a special effort
by the bar association the New Hampshire
Bar Association because I know that like
in Massachusetts I have the legal
advocacy and Resource Center
um which I I trained in a hundred
thousand years ago
um and then the law clinics at the law
school maybe some help there so I think
we have to be a little bit creative
maybe I see Annie's FaceTime but
to help with the integer caseload or
right anybody else
okay oh representative Gordon just just
comment and that is
I uh and I I think that some Overture
could be made to the governor's office
as well in terms of making change in the
department because I'm sure he's as
aware of the governor as aware of the
foreign
so all right so
let's just
kind of get into a little bit of the
wrap up here so at as director Malik I
said there's a there's a lot to unpack
so
um but
um
in terms of the path forward we're going
to have the executive session for the
whole committee
um in October at some point so I just
kind of want to get some consensus as to
where we want to go and what we want to
bring forth to
um
the broader committee so does anybody I
have my thoughts but I don't want to
kind of start with them so does anybody
have any thoughts that they'd like to
representative Lorenzo oh thank you Mr
chair well I would like to work towards
um passing SB 296 you know make that the
priority and that's you know
with our committee
okay
representative walper so unfortunately
uh passing SB 296 is not within our
purview
the best we could do is say we recommend
that right be reintroduced that's what I
mean and passed okay
and all that would do as it's written
would be to uh
remove the right of the respondent to
remove after finding is a probable cause
which I think would be a good thing
don't get me wrong
but I don't think it does anything to
resolve the
situations that we're hearing about and
the timeline of all of this
which is uh I think our greater concern
I think that's really why we're sitting
here
so I mean from my perspective uh the
reason that we wanted to interim study
this was because we had concerns about
the resources
um at the Human Rights Commission to be
able to satisfy uh the requirements of
296. so I think
um actually pretty early on uh with
respect to the work of the subcommittee
we came to an understanding that uh SB
296 its original language is
constitutional
um and uh that 48 other states already
do it and that the Human Rights
Commission does indeed have the
resources to do that so from that
perspective
um the core of SB 296 as we received it
I would be comfortable going to the
committee as a whole and saying yes we
recommend this for future legislation
it's constitutional other states do it
the resources are there boom so from
that perspective I think we're okay
there may be though an opportunity and
you know part of our discussions have
kind of unpacked some of the other
things that are going on at the Human
Rights Commission there may be though an
opportunity to add to that
um now we do have the performance audit
where we're going to hopefully go before
the lpaoc in and ask for something and
they all kind of look to see where where
does that kind of dovetail in with the
other priorities of the of the state
they may decide to go forward they may
not decide to go forward but the other
area where I do think that we had broad
agreement
was on the fact that um it's worth going
back and revisiting the rules
especially in light of the fact that
they've been expired I think it was said
for five years and so
you know while uh and I and I don't know
what the what what would constitute that
rule-making committee from jail car I I
would assume you would have folks from
the respondent side the claim inside you
would have folks from the HRC or not so
you have some uh representative Smith
thank you I think you're you know you
you're making a good point that we can
begin
um by saying
the bill having reviewed the bills that
came to us
um
the bill is fine as far as it goes
however
three other areas
that we think must be
um
looked into one
that we strongly urge
uh
jail car and the commission to work
together
to come up with new
rules
based on all the knowledge that we've
had since that's probably number three
but I I said it first so I don't forget
it
secondly that um
we uh strongly urge
um
uh the performance audit group
to
um
look into not the financial but you know
the uh operational uh
the performance piece of and third that
we clarify either
through rules or if necessary
through statute
exactly what is meant
by
um
uh
I'm having a blank
by probable cause thank you
um and uh and that
we believe that our research has shown
us that probable cause as it is
interpreted currently
um
by uh the commission uh
goes further than our standard
understanding of probable cause and
probable cause should very clearly be
just
the
initial judgment yet that yes which I
use the word triage but maybe that's not
the right word that yes this is
something worth pursuing and that
and I think we have to mention that
and hopes that
when could be us we could present
to um OLS
uh a new bill
everybody here except Ned could present
a new bill that
um
uh
that includes in it the language that we
think is fine that we got from the
Senate plus a clarification of the
interpretation of probable cause the
other two things are already legislative
and that would be gel car and
performance audit
so
yeah so does that make sense to people
the only issue that I have with the
probable cause definition
it's in the statute it says it makes the
determination the standard that's
applied is correct but then it says that
the standard after investigation
and I think that after investigation is
the issue because
it seems to me that you could find
probable cause after you do the
three-step process
and of the initial complaint submission
the
employer's response and then the
complainants
subsequent response you could make a
public cause without necessarily having
yes so just one second I set a question
then I'll I'll go right to you so you're
saying basically to leave that part open
maybe have an investigation maybe not
but basically provide that Latitude
but I think the way it's being
interpreted right now by the division
you have to have a full investigation in
order to find probable cause and I think
that's the issue is I don't think you
need a full investigation to have
problem to find probable cause and what
you're doing is basically adjudicating
the whole case and having investigator
adjudicate the case basically act as a
judge
adjudicate the case
and then give it to a commissioner to
make a finding a probable cause but
they're basically finding yeah
it's true or isn't true is is basically
their ruling
representative wolper
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman I
think we have a problem here
and the problem is in fact in the
statute
I just want to read a couple sentences
which is
which of these after the filing of any
one of the Commissioners designated by
the chair shall make with the assistance
of staff
prompt investigation and connection
during the course of the investigation
the commission
shall encourage the parties to resolve
their differences through settlement
negotiations
and in such Commission
ER
shall determine as such invest after
after such investigation that probable
for crediting the allegations of the
complainant
the commissioner shall immediately
Endeavor to eliminate the unlawful
discriminatory practice
and the what this is saying to me
is what does the human the reason we're
getting the kinds of reports that were
mentioned here which attorney
executive director Malachi says it's not
what we're doing now is because that's
what the statute calls for
this is in fact
if if
after such investigation the finding a
probable cause exists the commissioner
shall immediately Endeavor to eliminate
you know you know where that is it's an
RSA
354a colon 21 Roman 2A and if you have
the same copy I do it's about the fifth
line down begins with the word
determined
but that whole thing that I started is
354 Roman 2A
after following complaints it's all one
sentence and the commissioner has
already
immediately to Endeavor to eliminate the
and that's as far as it goes that's what
that's the whole investigatory part of
this statute
foreign
had the problem and then
to take steps necessary which would have
required a decision that
yes there's a problem here
it doesn't seem to me to be any
relationship between that language
and what would that happen
well and that could be right because it
seems to me this just says the commit
and file complaint and have an
investigation and whatever is decided
and I totally agree when with the report
there's equivalent of summary judgment
or as and this is talking about one
commissioner there's no such thing as a
yeah
right
right so
so it's totally understandable to me
that the investigators would be doing
all the work
to make
a case
and getting rubber stamped by the
commissioner
there's no Hearing in there there is no
hearing
foreign
commissioner showing her issue written
notice blah blah blah
answer charges and to three members of
the commission and then you have it here
but but this statute says you do an
investigation and then and the
commission an a commissioner
makes a determination and is immediately
immediately Endeavor to eliminate the
unlawful practice
and that's where this is breaking down
huh
well what but think about it the intent
is not that
somebody comes in makes a complaint
there's an investigation there's a
finding a probable cause and then
there's a hearing no
that is not what this says
it says they make a complaint there's an
investigation
and if there's probable cause
the commission is shall immediately
Endeavor to eliminate the unlawful
practice
so if we
if that fails
then there's another opportunity
for a hearing before the whole
Commission
I thought it was two years so maybe
maybe they're thinking
that oh yeah at the end of that section
so
any complaint file pursuance can be
removed after 180 days oh four yeah yeah
and administrative section of the
commission tell me exactly the position
brush up close each case or commits
adjudicated proceedings on Seth case
so close
if
so if we were to look at some of the
language you were talking about with
respect to probable cause representative
Accord
that would
based on representative Walker's comment
create a conflict right there chance to
change the statue so you have to get
into
um
so I just you know fool the committee do
we think that we
really want to get into that's that's a
lot of stuff to get into that we want to
if we have to really
sure
yes representative I'm thinking I'm just
listening to what you're saying and you
thought well do we want to get into that
we talked about a possible performance
audit so wouldn't it make sense to if in
fact there is going to be a performance
audit to write any
um statute after that
I mean I I think there are some simple
things you know that we can do
but I agree with you get getting into
some heavy meat and potatoes like this
um it's going to require some thought
um some interactive dialogue to just go
in and well I well I you know understand
and respect your comments it's it's
going to take some thinking and uh so I
even though the performance audit if
we're lucky enough to get it
um
there's there's a a a length to that I I
think the end product would be better
than if just the folks on the
subcommittee were to go into it that's
I no I I concur because as I the more I
think about this the more I think this
is meant to be a non-judicial procedure
or is this just an investigation and
if there's reason to believe that the
Discrimination has actually occurred
reason to believe probable cause
then there's a there's effort to um
mitigate the circumstances
to remove the discriminatory practice
or correct whichever is
but see we're not getting to that point
at all
until we go through this
very whole long thing and look for
hearings and then this and that's why we
have develop our removal
right because at the point in the
statute where probable cause is
determined
the commission is supposed to be taking
action
immediately
right
so allowing removal at that point is to
totally throw it the role of the
commission
and I think that that part we're all
we're all okay on but I think you know
in in light of that
I'm
I would I would even leave the probable
I think
broadly speaking it's it's adequate
maybe we can talk about how it's applied
um but I I just don't want to create
conflict within the statute that we
really haven't taken the time to look
into
um but
on to representative Smith's other point
which is gel car
um
so
I just want to follow up on
representative wolper's comment a little
bit about maybe writing that into the
statute that we would you know ask for a
commission or a formal convening of gel
car to do that
um
I I understand your comment is that
really necessary but I I think having
something that kind of forces the hand
would be good
should we should we be putting that
into the language of the stat of of
whatever we come out of here with
well I I don't think that's the way to
handle that I think the way to handle it
is in the report that we make
um uh as to the bill I mean and that
would then be on record
um and we then are free to
uh for someone to talk to the governor
about about the funding and we're also
free for someone to talk to the newly
formed gel car to say
this is something that needs to be done
and we have it in and we say here's the
report and we're showing you that I
oh representative walpark I agree with
representative Smith if we write a
report along the lines that we just
delineated right that we we think we
should do the remove the removal from
but we really think what needs to happen
is the rules need to be updated
then
everybody in the world including
director Malachi can take that
so well rather than put that
in the legislation just put it in the
okay so representative Smith you also
talked about funding
um are there thoughts from anybody about
requests for funding in the report or or
comments
oh
or we could say in the report that based
on the information the director has
given us we support our request
for additional funds uh and uh in order
for the agency to be able to carry out
its statue
role but uh and then meanwhile
we need
um
have you had your uh
your hearing yet for uh house
this is the on the governor's request
budget yeah
okay
so you think I think you could put in
there that uh
with uh in the current process
the resources are inadequate
to meet reasonable time frames for a
resolution of cases
as required by Statute
and that additional resources are
required
we'll give representative Oprah a minute
yeah so quick review I have five items
maybe good for cars
maybe four
to be included in our report
so the inaction of SB 296 report
language
um
and then you get to resources uh what I
had was resources above the normal
operational level are required to
address the backlog of cases
and current processes require additional
do it
yeah
no I I agree you you want to you want to
bring some stability over to the
commission that's I think vital
um and so it goes beyond the backlog
well it does yeah
but good
deal is to prevent the agency from
becoming a training agency because from
what
um director Malachi said is that people
come and they leave they leave to go to
you know more money or whatever so
okay so I mean I those uh those four
items dovetail in with my thoughts
everybody else agree
okay so what we'll do then is
um I think from a statutory perspective
uh in terms of
the bill is 296. we're good the rest of
it will go into the report
um we'll work to get something together
by the time that representative Gordon
convenes the committee as a whole and
will present that to the whole committee
so does anybody have any other thoughts
um representative wolper so uh Mr
chairman yeah
the concern the only concern that I
would have is if someone has to actually
write the report
and typically that would be go to all of
us to review before we submitted to the
full committee
so I would suggest that we decide uh
who's going to write it
that would be useful
and
we plan to meet uh maybe just before
the meeting for the whole committee
to redo it because we can't discuss it
any other way without having another
meeting
so we yeah so once uh
I had to look at my calendar
um and I'll get back to representative
Gordon on that and then he'll kind of
pull the rest of the committee
understand what their scheduling is like
we'll all get together when we know that
right October 19th
so when that comes out we'll we'll
schedule something then
to get to get the five of us together
so Mr chairman I would suggest that we
meet
for lunch
no we can't do it has to be a public
meeting right
yeah yes so like half an hour before
whatever the
schedule time for the regular full
it's all right well what what's what's
the date on that
subject to me checking like uh I worked
for him enough the other way around so
um
I said no wrong answer
um okay uh so that's fine so
but in terms of
um who is going to write the report I
was thinking to to be putting something
together unless you're volunteering
what
I'm happy to let you have it all right
so um yeah so I'll I'll uh I'll put
something together I've never written
one before but I'll figure it out and
then we'll get us all together and
um I can
yeah I I definitely am going to be
walking to the back of the room when
this is done uh and uh although she's
grimacing a bit so we'll see
before the night before I will do that
all right any other thoughts questions
all right well I I want to thank
everybody uh this has been a lot I as
director Malachi says a lot to unpack
and uh certainly a lot of learning for
me and everybody has been very patient
with the process and I've been very
appreciative of that and so we'll see
everybody again at some point on the
19th
thank you Mr chair and thank you for all
of your hard work it's I'm very
impressed